Okay guys, so here's another example and I'm gonna teach you a few more things in this video. So first of all
You want to mark out when when you're looking for these type of setups, you want to mark out the
New York midnight open. So the midnight midnight open is at around
12 a.m. New York time. So if I look at the
Open of this is the 10941
So this is the open right this candle. So I'm gonna mark this out as
Here midnight open
Okay, I'm gonna put it at the top
Perfect. I'm gonna decrease the size of it midnight open right and you want to mark out the
After midnight open you want to start?
Identifying the high of the day and the low of the day. So
The high of the day as as you can see this is the highest point after 12 am right?
So this is the high of the day. This is the highest point. So I'm gonna mark this high edge
high okay, and
You want to look for you can only look for the highs and lows before 9 30 once the 9 30 p. It starts
You don't want to look for you just you can only look for highs and lows before 9 30, okay?
so
As you can see we have a candle close at 9 30. So this is the actually the low of the day, okay?
So this here is the low of the day. So if I mark this out, this is the low L, okay?
Now this is considered as liquidity as well because this is actually the low of the day before the new
Ex session before the 9 30 period starts. Okay, so you wait for price to once you have identified the
The law of the day, which is actually this candle
Surprisingly, so we go to the one at a time frame and we will look for a liquidity sweep and if I play this through
We have the liquidity sweep now. We wait for market structure shift and if we play this through
We got this beautiful move. Oh, sorry. It was nothing
So if I play this through I think we got the market structure shift right around here
Boom boom boom right?
This is a break-off structure as well, but there's no fair value gap
So when there's no further gap you can go down to the go up to the two minute time frame and you can look for your entry as well
There's some favorable gap here
All right, so let's see if you get our entry from here and we do not so when you do not get your entry
you look for another market structure shift which happens right around here and
You take your entry from this fair value gap
right very simple
you take your entry and
As you can see now, I'm taking my entry from the very first favorite gap that was created as I explained before
So there's also some favorable gap around here
So I will put my stop loss right above right below this level just to be on the safe side
Because prices come down to this really gap and it can go up from there
So make sure you are cautious about that. So now where would you want to be taking your profit levels now?
There's some there's a high over around here
So I will take some partials here and then I will take some partials in and I will
There's some favorable gap around this level. So this would be my
Trade and let's see how this plays out
and
Kaboom
Yep, sorry for that that was a car outside my home, but anyways as you can see it hit the
The take profit level
You might have gone stop that break even here, but it just really depends on you how you trade
What's your risk management plan?
But anyways as you can see there was a sharp movement and as you can also see is
we before
We broke the structure with momentum. You can see this one two three candle. They have huge volume
So this is what you should be looking for. Okay
And then we had this beautiful fair value gap we filled this fair value gap and then we went up
Very simple guys. I'm gonna give you guys one more example and I'll end this lecture